i mean i think this was real like when
you were shooting that prank
and you guys your dicks were in that um
that chinese um
what are you calling that chinese finger
job yeah the chinese finger trap it's
the funniest thing ever but it looked
like that guy really pulled a knife on
you was gonna kill you
oh yeah and that was rel's first day of
shooting that was my co-star's first day
of shooting
he never had shot a hidden camera prank
in his life
and i kept being like no no it's okay we
got a safety protocol it's going to be
fine
we walked into the safe what's the
weight is there what's the safety
protocol
what do you have a safe word we have a
safe word if i know popcorn
that means you got to come in and save
me because i'm about to die why'd you
choose that word
i wanted a word that i would like never
use in real life in a scene the only
time you say the word
popcorn is when you're ordering popcorn
so it's not like
it couldn't be confused with some you
know something i was saying like in the
heat of the performance so you say to
your co-star don't worry we got this
thing down if some something really
dangerous happens i yell popcorn
everything's fine
but yeah of course you probably have
never yelled popcorn ever
i never yelled it and things did not go
fine and then i got so nervous when they
so
so we we went to this hood barber shop
with our dicks in a chinese finger trap
we we politely asked the barber for
scissors
and barbara was like oh hell no he
started looking for his gun
couldn't find his gun found his knife
chased us out of the thing with a knife
and we me and rel can barely run in that
thing because we're joined at the dick
so we're like
i like laurel and hardy running out of
there yeah and then
i was so nervous i forgot my own safe
word because i've never used it so
instead of yelling popcorn i was yelling
goosebumps
so new one no one knew what i was
talking about i was like goosebumps
goosebumps goosebumps just out of nerves
and it was like [ __ ]
popcorn and then my security guy jumped
in and did like a judo chop on the guy
and grabbed his knife
right and then we go hey you're in a
hidden camera prank thing
and then he was like oh y'all are
hilarious
you got me with that one he went from
like a murderous rage to like slapping
his knee
you you know you're responsible for the
movie i don't even know if you know this
do you know i don't know this no so when
the earlier times that i did the show
either the prostate karaoke time or the
time i wrote the sybian
one of the executives adam rosenberg
shout out
uh that was working at mgm heard my
interview
was like i love this guy he should work
with the jackass
producers i happen to be working with
jeff germain
and his producing team on this movie
like
developing it at the time that he heard
that and he was like why don't you guys
come in
and pitch pitch something together you j
you know that grandpa had just come out
and me and jeff uh pitched mgm and he
was like uh
i'm in let's do it that's really kind of
cool that that happened how could you
not yeah you're like a malcolm
gladwellian
connector you like brought us together